يمشون ويقفزون وقد يتوجهون الى مكان العمل
بدلا عنك قريبا عيون تراقب وتتحرك يدان
وقدمان جسم ليس بغريب عن العين البشريه
لكنهم ليسوا بل من صنع اياديهم اشكالهم
مختلفه ووظائفهم متعدده روبوتات شبيهه
بالبشر قد تحل مشكله نقص العماله شركه
تعمل على مشروع تقني هدفه تصميم روبوتات
شبيهه بالشكل البشري روحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي النموذج الاولي للروبوت سيكون
قادرا على المشي وتسلق السلالم وفتح
الابواب واستخدام الادوات وصناديق الرفع
وربما حتى اعداد العشاء اما في تفاصيل
التنفيذ فالشركه تخطط لانشاء مستودع وهمي
لاختبار نموذجهم الاولي الذي سيكون
كهربائيا بالكامل ويعمل لمده خمس ساعات
لكن عقبات قد تقف في طريق الخبراء اذ ان
الروبوتات الشبيهه بالبشر من الصعب جدا
بناؤها وهندستها لاداء موثوق به
التصميم سيستغرق عقودا حتى تتمكن
الروبوتات من تكرار الاشياء المعقده التي
يمكن لاجسامنا القيام بها لكن الحالمين
يبذلون قصار جهدهم في محاوله لتحقيق ذلك